hagamos un ejemplo en el que tomamos un
compás virtual y una regla virtual para
dibujar una línea tangente a un círculo
y se construye una línea que pasa por p
y sea tangente al círculo entonces bueno
se nos está pidiendo construir una línea
que vaya de p
y sea tangente a este círculo ahora como
puedes ver pero está sobre el círculo
que está fuera del círculo entonces aquí
tenemos las herramientas dice utilizar
el compás utilizar la regla o borrar
y bueno eso será necesario para poder
hacer esta construcción
entonces yo podría decir que bueno voy a
tomar aquí este segmento
voy a tomar esta línea que va de pepe y
decir que
esta tangente más o menos parece serlo
no pero en realidad esto no es preciso
esto no es exacto entonces para poder
hacer esta construcción lo que yo
necesito es un círculo que tenga como
diámetro
el segmento ps ahora cómo hago eso bueno
yo quiero un círculo
que tenga como diámetro al segmento pc
y sabemos que todo círculo tiene su
centro entonces el centro sería el punto
medio de este segmento que puede estar
por aquí pero otra vez no estoy siendo
exacta entonces como yo puedo encontrar
el centro de ese círculo que yo quiero
que tenga diámetro pc bueno pues lo que
yo puedo hacer lo que haré es lo
siguiente voy a tomar el compás
lo voy a centrar en ce
este círculo que estoy haciendo tendrá
un radio algo grande este es el radio
de este nuevo círculo ahora voy a tomar
otra vez el compás lo vuelvo a centrar
en sé
y voy a tomar otro círculo que tenga el
mismo radio que el círculo que acabo de
construir anteriormente pero este lo voy
a centrar en p
ahora qué está pasando aquí si puedes
observar este círculo y este se
intersectan en estos dos puntos
y que tienen interesante esos dos puntos
bueno
este punto equidista hace y ap
y también este punto es equidistante de
pdc como se es o bueno porque en este
círculo todos estos puntos equidistantes
entró al centro de ese círculo y todos
estos puntos equidistantes entró de este
círculo entonces todos estos puntos y
cristian ap todos estos puntos
equidistante y este punto está en
intersección de ambos entonces aquí
lista tanto ap y hace y este punto
también esta intersección de ambos
círculos entonces equidista apei hace
que quiere decir eso bueno pues quiere
decir que estos dos puntos están en la
línea que es perpendicular a este
segmento y perpendicular pero además
otra cosa que pasa por el punto medio de
este segmento entonces utilizó la regla
voy a poner un extremo del segmento aquí
en la intersección de esos dos círculos
y este otro punto acá en la segunda
intersección de los dos de los dos
círculos
ahí está entonces como te digo estos dos
puntos están sobre la línea que es
perpendicular y pasa por el punto medio
de este segmento así que ya encontramos
el centro del círculo que estábamos
buscando ajá utilizo el compás
los centros
justo aquí este círculo tendrá como
diámetro al segmento p s ahí está qué
bonito está quedando perfecto ahora
porque necesito yo ese círculo
bueno pues sabemos que si tenemos un
triángulo un triángulo que esté inscrito
en un círculo que tenga con uno de sus
lados un diámetro de ese círculo
entonces este triángulo resulta ser un
triángulo rectángulo es decir tiene un
ángulo recto entonces utilizo la regla
aquí tengo ya este segmento que es el
diámetro de este círculo amarillo
voy a poner
este extremo de este nuevo segmento aquí
este otro en la intersección del círculo
con centro en c y el círculo que
acabamos de construir ahí no es el la
intersección es
ahí está perfecto ahora utilizo otra vez
la regla
y voy a conectar estos dos puntos este
con el punto p así que este círculo
tiene a este triángulo inscrito tiene
sus tres vértices en el círculo este
triángulo es un triángulo rectángulo
porque tiene como lado
al diámetro de ese círculo entonces eso
me está indicando que este es un
triángulo rectángulo y ahora esto porque
es útil para construir una línea
tangente a este círculo centrado en c
bueno pues aquí se forma un ángulo recto
por este triángulo rectángulo y está la
perpendicular a ese segmento que es el
radio de este círculo porque porque este
es un ángulo recto entonces yo
simplemente puedo alargar ese segmento
para que se vea un poco más claro y ahí
la tenemos tenemos él tenemos la línea
que pasa por el punto p y que es
tangente al círculo concéntrense ahí
está entonces si no quedó claro lo que
tenía yo aquí
era a este triángulo que está inscrito
en este círculo amarillo ajá ese es un
triángulo rectángulo este ángulo recto
porque bueno porque ese triángulo tiene
un lado que es igual al diámetro del
círculo que construimos entonces como
aquí se forma un ángulo de 90 grados un
ángulo recto quiere decir que esta es la
tangente y ya quedó entonces aquí ya
puedes apreciar que no es tan fácil como
simplemente decir ah bueno pues yo voy a
tomar un segmento que tenga como uno de
sus puntos extremos al punto p y lo
coloco de tal manera que más o menos sea
tangente al círculo bueno eso no
exactamente es la tangente ahora hay
algunos que sí le pueden atinar pero la
construcción lo que nos garantiza que
esta es la tangente es todo lo que
hicimos y como puedes ver salen
bastantes patrones aquí queda un dibujo
muy bonito de hecho me dan ganas de de
poner este en un cuadro pero
al hacer estas construcciones puedes
apreciar eso y es importante aprender a
hacerlas para cuando se te pregunte no
se construye una línea que pase por un
punto y se tangente al círculo ya lo
sabrás hacer y bueno sería todo